- So wait, I heard that you're
about to get another trophy.
So, and it's from Ed Sheeran?
- Oh my God!
- So I want to know about this trophy.
- It's actually wild, I
thought it was a joke,
but he, it's a six-foot-two marble penis.
(laughs)
That is, it's two tons.
- What do you do with that?
- It's two tons, and I'm gonna have to
get it craned into my house.
- What, where, what, in your foyer?
Like what's gonna happen, like where?
- Well I want to turn it into a fountain.
(audience laughs)
Which I think will be hard to do.
- Is this a gift that he
gives people normally?
- He gives people concrete penises.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I'm not the first.
- Ed, my email is-
- He'll do it, he'll do it!
- I don't want a concrete,
I kind of want a concrete.
- Yeah, you do.
- And this is my backyard
and my concrete penis.
- You'd so want it.
Please name it.
- Oh, we should name it together.
- Okay.
- Phillip?
- Phil, wow, how proper.
- Yeah.
- You like it?
- Kevin?
- That reminds me of Home Alone
so it feels a little weird.
(laughs)
It's a little weird.
- Oh my God.
- No, we're gonna think
of one, a good one.
Duke of Hastings?
- Oh, I like that!
- Yeah!
- I like that, I'm gonna steal that.
- Did you like Bridgerton?
- Yes I did, I did like it.
- Duke of Hastings is nice.
- Yeah, I'm just saying,
sounds grand and six-two.
No segue there!